this is the reuben report direct message
i am dave rubin according to the
documents in front of me
on my trusty ipad and what we're going
to do with this show which we launched
last week is three days a week roughly
sometimes it'll be four
sometimes maybe it'll be five sometimes
maybe two shows in a day as we get
closer to the election
uh i'm gonna be waking up having my
trusty cup of coffee
and sitting down with my producer
michael and we're going to pick
just two or three stories of the day
that i think sum up
the sort of political political cultural
and social madness that we're all
dealing with i'm going to try to lay
them out for you guys in an easily
digestible way
and hopefully not make you feel crazier
because pretty much
everybody else doing anything news
related is trying to make you crazy
uh so today we're gonna cover three
stories which i'm gonna briefly tell you
about right now and then we'll get into
each one
first off uh you know when i did my
august off the grid thing
i came back and i thought you know one
of the things i'm gonna do less of
even though i'm i'm pretty good about it
i think but one of the things i'm gonna
do less of
is get involved in twitter spats right
twitter drama celebrity verse celebrity
politician
verse regular person regular person
destroys other regular person
i'm going to try to do a little bit less
of that and be less involved in those
kind of things
but over the labor day weekend candace
owens
who you guys all know who's a good
friend of mine and cardi b
the rapper they got into a twitter
blowout
that i think is actually totally
politically and culturally relevant
and worth diving into so we're going to
talk about that a little bit uh then
we're going to talk about dick morris
who was a former democrat he was
a bill clinton advisor when bill clinton
was president
uh he has now uh turned he has turned he
is now
joined the dark side he is now a
republican
uh and he was on a radio show on wabc in
new york and he had an interesting
commentary on the fact that he thinks
that trump will win reelection
he will keep the swing states but then
that this will all be kicked back to the
courts and ultimately have to be decided
by chief justice john roberts we're
going to talk about
that and then we're going to talk about
a story that we we talked about last
week
um you may remember nancy pelosi uh
up in san francisco wonderful uh
representative we have up there
and the leader of the house she uh went
and got a haircut even though she was
telling people she couldn't get haircuts
well now protesters are showing up at
her house
with hair irons hanging them in trees
it's a whole brouhaha
but before i get to that real quick i
wanted to mention that it was
labor day weekend here and we had record
record temperatures
in los angeles it was completely bananas
on saturday there were parts of la very
close to where i lived just
10 or 15 minutes away that got up to i
think woodland hills was 121 degrees
there were literally
uh orange cones you know that they put
in the streets to move traffic that were
melting into the streets
it was about 115 where i live it was
unbearable and our mayor
eric garcetti god bless them instead of
doing anything to fix the power grid or
address these issues
knowing that temperatures have been
wacky and we get fires and all sorts of
stuff and that the air quality when you
open up your
apple weather thing the air quality is
like you're going to die today i thought
that was a little excessive
um but instead of doing anything to fix
the the power grid and ensure that we'd
all be able to use air conditioning you
know like in most
um functioning countries he basically
told us all to unplug things
and set your thermostats up to 78 which
it's just so obvious this is such an
example of what democrats do with
everything
which is you think he was sitting there
in 78 degrees
in his house in his mansion and and
pulling out appliances it's like no
freaking way and this is the same thing
with
pelosi getting the haircut and the rest
of it all right
last thing before we get to the stories
guys we are doing the direct message
in conjunction with the fine folks over
at
blaze tv and you guys can jump over the
blaze they've got a really
interesting documentary right now it's
called riding the dragon and it really
goes
into the biden family connections with
the communist party in china
and the over billion dollars that hunter
biden's company hunter biden of course
is joe biden's son
uh that he got even though hunter biden
had no
experience in the energy sector and the
money that he got
and a whole bunch of things that the
biden family and the communist party of
china
have been doing together and you know
it's a documentary they lay it out and
you can decide if you want to check it
out
you can become blaze tv subscriber and
watch the entire documentary
uh start your free trial today and save
20 bucks off a one-year subscription
with the code dragon 20 just head over
to blazetv.com
now let's do the news okay so first up
cardi b
versus candace owens now i know you all
know candace owens she's been on the
show many times
actually her new book blackout just came
out
and uh we're gonna interview her we're
gonna be putting that up in just a
couple days
uh i love candace card's on the table
right like
first off by the way i should say when
i'm doing these i don't consider myself
a journalist i'm just someone telling
you
the news and giving you my perspective
there's too many journalists out there
that are just the people that are
talking their opinions uh but so card's
on the table i i love canada she's a
good friend of mine
uh and cardi b i'm not a huge rap fan i
always
tell people i like chill ambient music
and then i like the old crooners i like
frank sinatra
i like frankie valli pretty much anyone
named frank apparently
but cardi b's a rapper she's done
interviews with joe biden and instagram
lives with
uh aoc so she's involved in the
political world
and uh she also has this whap song which
was a huge hit over the summer i didn't
know about it until a couple days ago
and i got back on the grid
but whap stands for wet ass [ __ ]
and it involves a bucket and apparently
she's got some problems
uh but it's a big song it's it's blowing
up right now
so this is candace owens versus cardi b
and and i'm not just doing this to be
silly i think they actually got into
something kind of substantive here and
it started
when candace was on ben shapiro's
sunday special let's take a look at the
clip i completely agree with your
assessment about cardi b
um it is one of the biggest insults if
black americans are not insulted
by the fact that joe biden who has been
hiding in his basement um you know for
the entire year
made an appearance that came up because
he was going to do an interview with
cardi b do we do we have nothing better
to offer
i mean this would be akin to donald
trump saying i'm going to give no
interviews but he came up and he decided
to give an interview
to justin bieber right i mean which i
actually justin bieber i'm sorry i know
you're a christian man i don't want to
put you in the same boat as cardi b
um but it would be absurd right white
america would go what what is this why
why are you being interviewed by justin
bieber and it's because you're pandering
right you're pandering you look at cardi
b's instagram you see she has millions
of followers
and you think okay this is an illiterate
person and if i if i appeal to this
illiterate person and she does
oh like she literally did uh in the
middle of this interview
and they think she's cool she's hip just
by sitting here and
and taking this interview black people
vote for me it's basically saying black
people you are stupid
you are dumb and you're so foolish i
mean do you think what if she just said
in the middle of the interview
joe biden can you name one cardi b album
you know jeremiah do me a favor just one
cardi b lyric
he couldn't do it of course he's not
because he's being handled and they're
saying black people like this person
this is what they're into
and and so here you go talk to her okay
so cardi b
then heard what candice said and she hit
back she did a couple videos i think
four videos on instagram she wasn't
on camera but you could hear her talking
and the exact quote that she said she's
talking about candace
she says she has an identity crisis just
because she's black
doesn't mean she gives a f about blacks
and you can hear cardi b also saying
that candace owens husband george
uh is part of a group that she likened
to an upper class kkk in the uk now
first off i was at candace at george's
wedding
george is a great guy uh they are a
fantastic couple
the wedding was one of the most
spectacular weddings i've ever been to
and it was just filled
with with love and there were black
people and white people and there were
straight people and gay people
and there were republicans and democrats
it was it was a truly
uh just just an absolutely wonderful
wedding with
with a meeting of families george comes
from an upper-class family in the uk
candace comes from philly from mostly a
lower middle-class family and that
everybody was just
dancing and having a great time so like
just this nonsense
from cardi b but anyway that's what her
take on what candace said was
and then uh you know candace so she's
not just gonna sit there and take it
so candace uh followed up with a couple
tweets
and i'm gonna read them to you she said
malcolm x warned us
years ago about the puppetry of
interviews like cardi b
and joe biden he always spoke out
against the white
liberal game of using entertainers as
pawns
this isn't really about you cardi b this
is about black america waking up
to democrat racism she went on in
another tweet
to say never listen to a person that has
private security
but wants the public police defunded
never listened to a millionaire that
made it here in america but trashes our
country
these hollywood idols are frauds leading
sheep down paths they never took
when they discovered success so so
candace makes what i think are pretty
cogent salient points and cardi b then
jumps back in cardi b says well paying
taxes is something that as much as i
hate it's a reality i will always have
to pay but i rather my tax money go to
free education
than police funding use my money on
something useful
your president use our tax money to fund
his empty campaign runs so trump uses
his campaign money he uses the tax money
to fund
his campaign is that is that right well
candace jumped back in
and said one your tax dollars are ready
to go
already go to free education genius that
is true
two no campaign uses tax dollars for
funding that is illegal
that is also true and three defunding
police initiatives has
led to 200 increases in black men
getting shot in inner cities stop
supporting
black people dying anyway they've gone
back and forth a little bit more there's
some memes involved and you know
retweeting the haters and lovers and the
whole thing
but i think this is worth talking about
because it's illustrating
what is happening here you can either
think
that the policies that got everything
wrong
if you believe that the black community
has been left behind
and that there's a policing problem and
a jailing problem and all of those
things
then those are all policies of the past
that you would want to look at and say
what happened
now as you know i have talked to people
like thomas soule and larry elder
and david webb and many others who
believe that though
the policies that the democrats
installed
helped break down the black family thus
leading to all of these
other problems i know that's a dangerous
topic to talk about
but it is the truth and then the
democrats get people
stuck on the dole and you can't get off
and can't get a better job because if
you get a better job
then you're going to lose the benefits
lose the place where you live
and all of those things that is not a
shot at any black person or any person
period that's on the public dole
it's just a nature of reality if you're
given x amount
it's going to be much harder for you to
put that aside and go get what's yours
which is
the american dream so when you see
candace and cardi b going after this
uh and going into this fight first off
you know putting aside the twitter
fights they sort of are what they are
but the battle of ideas here is actually
real and important and one of the things
that for as crazy as the world seems
right now one of the things that i think
is very cool
is that whether you love cardi b or you
love candace or whatever it is
uh especially on the cardi b side let's
assume that most of cardi b's fans are
not traditional
political people right candace is maybe
she now comes
more from that world but if cardi b's
people are now seeing her get involved
into this fight with candace and then
reading the stuff well
maybe some of them are waking up so
that's why i thought this was actually
relevant and not just
i'm not just doing a girl cat fight on
twitter kind of thing
so we will see where these fights lead
us
i suspect there will be many more such
fights
in the days to come story number two
here is that uh dick morris who was
a bill clinton advisor you know
20 plus years ago he was a democrat and
a bill clinton advisor
he later transitioned let's say to
becoming a republican
he was on wabc radio this morning and he
was talking about
how he believes that trump will win he
believes that
the uh the states in the middle right
those states that could go either way
the purple states as we call them
uh that they are gonna break towards
trump as they broke towards trump
in 2016. uh but that that will not
be enough he's got a couple interesting
quotes here that are that are worth
laying out
what he says is that blue state
governors are mailing out
tens of millions of ballots they're
going to be returned with a vote on them
probably for biden day after day
week after week you're going to find
another million ballots counted here
another half million there
and gradually these democratic liberal
secretaries of state who are in charge
of the election in most of these blue
states
will say we're sorry it turns out that
biden carried wisconsin
not trump then he argues that the next
thing that
trump is going to have to do is going to
bring lawsuits to the state courts
and that the state courts are and this
is his quote
are largely liberal largely democrat and
they will rule in favor of the state
that biden carried it and then his
argument is that ultimately
this will get to the federal level which
is going to get it to the supreme court
and then this will all
fall on the feet of chief justice
john roberts now let me just say this
that
would be an epic bonkers
disaster okay that would be absolutely
absolutely terrible the idea
that the supreme court would ultimately
be making the decision
of what votes count when they count that
they could even count them properly
and make a sort of decision that
everyone would accept
is seriously seriously dangerous by the
way this isn't
uh the first time that something like
this would have happened because
obviously we have
had this with uh bush and gore you know
20 years ago
uh but this is seriously seriously
dangerous and one of the things that i'm
worried about right now is
everybody regardless your republican
your democrat lefty righty conservative
liberal whatever it is
everyone's sort of setting the table so
that if your guide doesn't win
that somehow you're going to be able to
argue
that somehow you're going to be able to
argue that the election is
is invalid bernie sanders sent out a
crazy long twitter thread talking about
how
the democrats are going to have to
figure out a way to make sure
everything's counted if trump won't step
down and by the way this is something
the democrats have been
well frankly the democrats have been
doing this right since
since the election of 2016 between
impeachments and fake scandals
and undermining the president every
which way and
i think you could probably make the
argument the other way that if it's very
a very close win for biden that of
course there's going to be a certain
amount of trump supporters and
republicans that won't accept the
election i see that version
less i see that less because there is
there does at least in my mind seem to
be more of a respect
for law and order in the system so much
of what's coming out of the democrats
these days
is burn down the system so it's like if
you don't get the guy
you get in well your whole modus
operandi has burned down the system
anyway
so let's just really burn it down if we
don't get the guy there's less of that
when it comes to
conservatism because there's a belief in
the system there's a belief in the three
branches of government there's a belief
in the constitution
and the bill of rights and things like
that but i'm not going to say that
there's no version
of that on the right um this is a major
problem though because if you think
we're polarized right now and i would
venture to say that we are at least
slightly polarized here in america
um the idea that this would be taken to
the supreme court
is dangerous and scary and it's it's
sort of
you know look we're seeing people right
now there were a bunch of videos just in
the last couple days
of just people that are eating food at
restaurants having a drink at outdoor
restaurants
and then black lives matter antifa
people come
and they literally just attack the
restaurants they're throwing glasses at
people breaking things
i'm sure you guys have seen these videos
and if you think that that's bad well
imagine what it will feel like when half
the country doesn't accept
the results of the election and at a
certain level it does feel like the
media
is kind of ramping us all up to to
accept that that is the inevitable
outcome here that half the country is
going to be left
you know basically basically wanting
revolution
and that's really really dangerous and
for those of us
that are you know somewhat clear-minded
that somehow accept that you're not
going to always have your guy
in office and that what you want to do
is lay the frown
the framework the groundwork for better
ideas to get across
well we better start trying to you know
lower the temperature on this thing i
think that's what i'm trying to do
and we'll see if other people join me in
it but if this thing goes to the supreme
court
it's gonna forget everything related to
violence and people on street
just imagine the months and months if
not year
of craziness that will lead us to and
just the endless
tenor of this right it's not healthy in
a good democracy i think you want a
government that's so small
that you don't have to be obsessed with
it because it's like oh i didn't get the
guy i wanted well he can't do that much
and the trade-off there of course is oh
you get the guy you want it and he can't
do everything you want
that's what a healthy democracy should
be going for i'm not
quite sure that that's what we have at
the moment
all right guys one one more story for
you that i think
sort of fits in everything that i'm
talking about here
about how do we get out of the craziness
because i just mentioned
you know this idea of these people that
are showing up at restaurants
just think of the gall of somebody so
you have a political belief
whatever your black lives matter excuse
me whatever your black lives matter
antifa
progressive tolerant diverse beliefs are
whatever your political views are
you're marching down the street and then
you just decide that you can
you know attack people and ruin people's
times who are you know sitting with
their families
having dinner well last week we saw
nancy pelosi who is the speaker of the
house basically
in many ways the most powerful democrat
i think
i think you could argue that she she's
more powerful at least at the moment
than joe biden i mean putting aside all
of joe biden's
mental problems and and you know the
whole
putting aside all of that um you know
she is the speaker of the house right
she she moves the levers
of congress so she's got a lot of power
uh she has been
uh one of the chief instigators in these
lockdowns and of course she
shows up at the salon she's now
blaming the salon owner right she's
blaming the salon owner
for setting her up as if she didn't know
the laws that
she herself was passing which it's like
you know the buck
stops with me that's not a policy that
these people have the buck stops with
nobody
uh that that is one of the problems for
modern politicians in general it's like
there we need people
that say these are my decisions i'm the
decider
and we're gonna live with these
decisions and instead
she gets her hair cut while other people
aren't getting their hair cut while
people
who own salons who own restaurants who
own mom and pop
stores and whatever it might be they're
all going out of business but she's
still able to get a haircut she's able
to eat her ice cream and all of that
stuff
uh so she did that and then as if it
wasn't bad enough that she got the
haircut she got caught then she blames
the salon owner the salon owner by the
way
was on tucker carlson last week and
basically was like
you know pelosi's a liar uh but putting
some of those things away where this
leads and sort of the transition i'm
making from
when people are attacking you at a
at a restaurant when you're sitting
outside and and they don't know what
your poli uh
political beliefs are they just think
that oh you're sitting there and we
our cause is so just and this is what
this is what
the the marxists and the progressives
have tricked everybody into
thinking they've tricked young people
into thinking that our cause is so just
and we're fighting so many nazis
that we can do whatever we want whenever
we want if we want to rip down a statue
that's fine if we want to
burn down a building that's fine if
someone's driving a car off down a
bridge
you're allowed to stop them like a
literal troll would do in a
fairy tale um
but you take that right you take that
mindset well what happened so then what
did the people on the other side do
well then people who don't like nancy
pelosi showed up at her house and they
brought hair dryers and
hair irons and curling irons and i don't
know what all that stuff
is but they hung a bunch of them in the
tree outside of her house to mock
her hypocrisy now again i don't mind
protests i love
protest right protest is the most
american thing that you can do
exercising your free speech is the most
american thing you can do so i don't
have a problem
with these people but what i do have an
issue with is just the creeping
disintegration of all of the norms like
you don't want people showing up
to politicians homes the same way you
may remember
what was it six or eight months ago when
activists
blm and antifa people showed up at
tucker carlson's home and his wife and
his
i think three kids were inside and they
were scared out of their minds
uh you don't want this leaking in
we've watched politics leak into every
part of society right it's ruined sports
it's ruined movies and tv shows actually
in the next couple days i'll do a
segment on that
uh just trying to find something on
netflix that hasn't been completely
infected
by social justice is just so freaking
difficult right now
but in any event we now have people
showing up at politicians homes and i
see that just as dangerous whether they
were showing up
at pelosi's home or whether whether they
were showing it up at mitch mcconnell's
home
a quote from one of the protesters was
what she has done is a slap in the face
of not just a salon owner but
every woman every man every person who's
unemployed in the state of california
who has just lost their jobs and lost
their livelihoods
many of whom are my friends well you
know what you're absolutely right
and i'm not telling you not to be out
there but what i am telling you is i
decided as you guys know to stay in
california and
fight i think we can get rid of people
like pelosi i think we can get rid of
people like eric garcetti here in los
angeles
i think we can get rid of people like
gavin newsom the governor
and we can vote in more centrist
conservative small government thinking
people we've got a chance
i said it last week and i'll keep saying
it ronald reagan he was the governor
of california and he was a democrat
actor before that we've got a chance
people